ce qu'on nous a déjà proposé 10000 euros
pour une nuit quoi
personne ne touche à part mon mari
je m'appelle Amandine pelissa j'ai 36
ans je m'appelle Alexandre Pélissard
j'ai 42 ans je l'ai connu par une amie à
mobile il voulait la sauter ma copine ce
que je suis chez moi reparti avec 8
enfants on en ayant un parent pendant
des années crois-moi que tu peux
vraiment arriver à t'oublier surtout
quand tu allais être 7h sur 8 dans la
nuit et puis qu'il te reste juste 8h
pour ton couple donc tu vois c'est léger
après mais ouais vraiment on serait
connait très libéré on avait fait à
l'époque une émission sur M6 voilà
capitale parce que en fait à ce moment
là je vendais énormément énormément sur
vinted et j'étais a priori une
demi-heureuse de France en 2019 et après
ça du coup TF1 on nous a contacté pour
le lancement de 1800 familles nombreuses
qui n'existait pas donc nous on est
arrivé en saison 1 effectivement la
visibilité qu'on a eu et la notoriété
que la notoriété que ça a généré ce
programme on a réussi à faire quelque
chose de notre notoriété donc moi je
suis devenue influenceuse donc on a
commencé à voilà on a ouvert une
entreprise parce qu'en fait c'est des
revenus imposable et j'ai commencé à
faire des placements de produits j'ai
une communauté on a une communauté qui
est très impliquée très investible très
présente de maman comme moi beaucoup de
couple et donc on a fait dans mon
placement de produit on en fait toujours
du coup une fois qu'on est nous deux et
ben nous deux c'est nous deux il y a
plus d'enfants il y a plus rien il y a
que lui et moi et on se retrouve comme
on sait jamais retrouvé en fait depuis
le début quoi et moi c'est vrai que ça
faisait quelques temps que j'avais envie
de me lancer sur la plateforme mime j'en
ai parlé à Alexandre Alexandre début tu
es pas trop chaud et on tourne encore
avec TF1 ce moment-là donc c'était un
petit peu compliqué et donc il y a
quelques temps il y a quoi il y a un
mois de ça donc je lui dis écoute
pourquoi on ne savait pas et il me dit
oui vas-y toi je dis non par contre je
veux pas faire ça sans toi c'est Nous
Deux ou rien appris il m'a dit bon vas-y
ouais on va on y va il a eu envie de se
lancer dans l'aventure mime et on s'est
lancé tous les deux et à notre grande
surprise en fait ça a eu un succès
incroyable pourtant je suis pas un top
model mais bon c'est devenu viral en
fait parce que ça choque énormément de
gens que parce qu'on n'est pas de
famille nombreuses on se lance dans la
monétisation de
ou pornographique quand on me dit ta
parole au canapé
que le harcèlement quand on dit tes
enfants tu penses à tes enfants pour mes
enfants ils sont très heureux les
enfants ils sont harcelés en fait et
notre fils a 17 ans bientôt je dois
demander son avis avant quand on lui a
dit qu'est-ce que tu en penses si on
fait ça avec ton père bon allez-y moi je
m'en fous ça vous fait plaisir ça vous
fait du bien pas de mal à se faire du
bien et ben non il y a pas de mal faire
du bien ça c'est important d'en parler
des lixes l'hélix c'est les fuites donc
les fuites en fait comme nous on
monétise nos contenus sur des
plateformes privées payantes le le la
licence de diffusion appartient aussi
tant que notre compte est actif ça n'a
pas lieu de fuiter c'est interdit en
fait c'est pas libre de droit les
contenus sont pas libres de droits comme
sur Instagram ou Facebook les réseaux
sociaux gratuits en gros en visuel c'est
un peu comme insta pas un mur tu as un
filtre avec des photos bon des photos
évidemment qui sont pas de l'ordre
d'Instagram nous notre Instagram
formidable c'est nos partages familiaux
on partage on va dire enfin voilà usuel
lambda quoi ce qui s'adresse à tout le
monde oui mes souhaits sont des contenus
particuliers qui s'adressent à ceux qui
veulent voir ça qui ont envie de voir ça
donc effectivement pour y accéder il
faut s'abonner nous on abonnement au
prix le plus bas pour qu'après en fait
justement ceux qui ont envie s'abonne
sur le mur il y a beaucoup de contenu
beaucoup de photos des vidéos qui sont
sexy qui peuvent être voilà un peu de
charme un peu érotique mais on voit pas
grand chose on envoie assez pour avoir
envie d'en voir plus en fait c'est ça et
ceux qui ont envie d'en voir plus du
coup on peut nous demander déjà ce qu'on
veut nous voir en lingerie on
porte-jarretelles machin il le verront
un truc voilà mais ceux qui veulent voir
plus après ils nous demandent en média
privé et là c'est des médias du coup
qu'on va l'unité le prix de la vidéo
varie selon les demandes ça va de 50 à
50 euros
la vidéo et ouais ça peut aller voilà de
la vidéo toute simple moi toute seule
jusqu'à une vidéo entre nous enfin voilà
les Lim
seul enfin après
horrible je trouve beaucoup plus beau
normal un rapport
avec
des coups enfin des fouets on est dans
ce délire là depuis un petit moment déjà
voilà après vraiment les seules choses
qu'on refuse c'est la skate foncièrement
dégueulasse et donc les rapports à
plusieurs personnes quoi ça c'est bon et
là évidemment les rapports en réel c'est
niet une avant il voulait dessus l'autre
jour une avenante faire caca je crois
aussi
qu'il voulait que vous voulez que je
l'engueule comme si j'étais sa maman et
que je donne des ordres non des choses
quand même assez incroyable historique
dans la santé c'est vraiment c'est
divers et varié quoi ce qui revient le
plus quand même tout ce qui est le plus
demandé les rapports un peu quand même
sans nous en ont beaucoup ou tu mais
après c'est lui qui est dominant on
dirait pas mais c'est lui qui me donne
pas du tout au lit c'est lui qui me
frappe c'est pas moi il met des coups de
martinet et non ça ça revient beaucoup
le club ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
connaissait même pas quand on a
recherché sur Google ça voulait dire
quoi donc les pieds ça c'est énorme on
nous demande tout le temps
et puis toi c'est un peu contorsionniste
quand même va falloir qu'on s'y mette
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de demandes
l'offre et la demande chérie faut
répondre dans cette énorme quoi et puis
pas mal de ouais de vidéos type à malin
quand même ça c'est le truc qu'on nous
demande le plus et aussi beaucoup qu'il
me demande en disant leur nom lequel
j'ai encore c'est moi toute seule du
coup c'est lui qui filme et comme cette
vidéo qui oui avec les mises en scène
genre secrétaire secrétaire machin ça
c'est vrai que ça revient pas mal et
quand donc je suis toute seule c'est mon
chéri qui filme et quand on tourne les
deux donc on à ce moment-là de téléphone
qui filme avec deux angles de ce qu'il y
en a qui veulent de la vue de près et
d'autres qui veulent toute la scène en
fait donc voilà pour tous les goûts
ouais on a du mal à gérer toutes les
demandes et justement on nous a proposé
il y a plein de gens des community
managers qui nous contactent pour
proposer de gérer les demandes à notre
place ça on veut pas on veut que ce soit
nous deux qui répondent on demande en
fait des gens donc il y a que nous qui
gérons ça donc c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué parce qu'on a énormément de
demandes donc on met du temps à répondre
à tout le monde mais c'est beaucoup trop
important pour qu'on ait beaucoup trop
intime contre de Lexa à quelqu'un de
tierce personne c'est notre travail il
faut répondre au message facile comme on
dit en fait voilà pour répondre à tout
le monde faut gérer tout ça il faut
enfin c'est c'est plus qu'un temps plein
quoi nous on n'a jamais fait des grosses
nuit on a plein gros capital sommeil et
tant mieux donc on dort pas beaucoup
parce qu'entre le temps on compare à
répondre aux messages et donc on passe
il reste plus beaucoup de temps pour
dormir quoi après c'est ça la journée on
a écrit gosses toute la journée donc non
vraiment on a voilà on est multi
casquette c'est on est des parents et
avant d'être des parents et ben on a un
coup et nos enfants
dans les yeux donc à un moment donné
faut arrêter de diaboliser ce qui n'a
rien de diabolique en fait tout le monde
en a besoin tout le monde ça rend
heureux en fait ça libère des deux pas
une dans le cerveau physiologiquement ça
rend heureux les gens et on fait du mal
à personne donc top en fait quoi et en
plus ça nous permet de générer des
revenus confortables donc voilà là ça
fait un mois peut-être pas dire moi je
m'en fous très vite il veut pas donner
une fourchette de la fourchette que tu
as envie en trois semaines on va dire
entre 25 et 30 oui en plus il y a des
couples aussi il y a beaucoup de couples
en fait qui nous demande aussi des
contenus et des femmes il y a beaucoup
appris qu'une remercie parce qu'en fait
c'est parce qu'en fait on les rend
heureux en fait c'est ça qu'il faut ou
après même moi ça me dépasse parce que
moi je trouve que j'ai rien
d'exceptionnel je vais au doute enfant
j'ai 36 ans et des femmes sont beaucoup
plus jolies que moi beaucoup plus
attirantes que moi mais il y en a plein
qui te disent qu'en fait ils ont
fantasmer sur toi depuis 3 ans qui doit
la télé nanana et que après 8 enfants tu
es belle tes trucs tu es machin tu leur
envoies un contenu après il te remercie
et poliment et en fait il y a pas il y a
très peu le côté pervers en fait il est
très peu présent il y a peu de fou de
pervers et même moi ça m'a surpris il y
a vraiment de tout ça va du chef
d'entreprise ou truc de la police la du
GIGN là qui nous a écrit hier encore des
gens connus des missions de télé de Top
Chef mais en fait ça va de tout du mec
marié qui se plante à 23h quand sa femme
dort enfin ça va de tout des jeunes de
25 ans de 22 23 25 ans et ça va vraiment
il y a vraiment tous les profils et tu
as 40 ans aussi et toi aussi de trois
pervers de 3 mais cela on les bloque
nous on est très terre à terre en fait
on vit au jour le jour on profite en
fait de ce qui nous arrive pour
l'instant on se rend compte que
cette monétisation de cette notoriété là
c'est vraiment fonctionnel plus que
fonctionnel et vraiment lucrative en
fait et je pense que tant qu'il y a
quelque chose à faire et à prendre là
dedans on le fera après on n'est pas con
on s'est rebondir quand il faudra
changer de casquette on changera de
casquette on est multi casquettes c'est
pas il y a pas c'est pas le souci
pendant ce temps-là nous on va à l'abri
nos enfants on s'éclate on s'est
retrouvé en plus après avoir passé une
période difficile on a eu des problèmes
de couple il y a quelques mois enfin
vraiment on s'est retrouvé dans une
complicité symbiose incroyable et on est
heureux on rend les gens heureux et
pourvu que ça dure quoi